[Music]
[Applause]
seth greenberg from the mothership
basketball analyst joins us on the
program seth were you bothered by tom
brady maybe uh hijacking selection
sunday yesterday
i just figured he wanted to take some
pressure off michigan being in 11 seed
so i understood
you know tom brady everything he does
has a purpose you know we want to take
care of juwon howard to kind of take a
little pressure off him they made it
into the tournament so he decided to
make the announcement that uh look he
could have waited a week but you know
those type of things you know dan those
you can't hide those things someone
would have broken it and he wanted to
control the narrative so billows on the
other hand was not happy
really
yeah he was not happy you know i mean
like this is our next three weeks and
this is this is our super bowl for the
next three weeks
well you know in the middle of it we got
shafty on our bracketology
another michigan guy and that's why i
say it's a conspiracy wow i mean
brady makes his announcement and another
michigan guy jumps in all of a sudden
people don't realize that michigan's at
11 and life is good i'll well billus is
always upset at something so i
understand that but yeah he tom brady
ruining the big day for for jay billis
do your neighbors ask for advice when
they fill out their brackets
my neighbors my daughters my former
players uh yeah people and then and then
when you're wrong by the way
they kill you they absolutely
and i let you know you're my favorite
thing is you go through this because you
know with social media and everything
like i picked alabama to lose
to rutgers the winner of the playing
game so because of that because of that
that's why you don't have a coaching job
because you don't know that alabama's
gonna win
i said okay that's all right i
understand that
whatever you say i mean like like you're
going to make half more people happy
happy people are going to be upset when
you make a pick and if i really knew the
answer i wouldn't be talking to you i'd
be in vegas and then walking over to my
yacht
all right the top four seeds any problem
no i think tennessee you know again a
lot of people
disagree but i think tennessee would win
in the sec tournament kind of played
their way into a number one i think some
guys played their way out i look at
baylor and you know what baylor has had
an incredible year but without jonathan
chamber chachua without lj crier if you
look at their team in this moment in
time not what they did when they won i
think their first 15 games
their team in this moment in time isn't
the number one seed not saying they're
not a good team because they're a very
good team tennessee how they played the
teams they beat whether it's kentucky
twice whether it's arizona whether it's
auburn i think they might have earned
their way to a one
obviously i was wrong
you know if you're of a certain age you
don't look at gonzaga as that cute
little program somewhere in washington
you know that that it was maybe 20 25
years ago
now you look at them as
like they're one of the powerhouses in
college basketball when did it change do
you think the
national perception of gonzaga from
being that cute little school to
you got to knock them off they're great
they're as blue blood as any team in the
last 10 years i mean i think someone
gave me a stat they've won more at cwa
tournaments in the last 10 years games
than than anyone in the country i mean
think about that and it's changed
everything they've done dan because i
mean like you see the guys they're
recruiting yeah i mean they're
recruiting dudes
i mean they recruit they're beating
north carolina for players to be in
kentucky for players uh
their roster is as good as any roster in
the country now i tell you the one thing
they have done they've they've still
been able to keep
their culture their environment
their identity
of more of
outside the main line
but but in terms of their program
you can't deny it they do what they have
to do in a non-conference they play a
great schedule and then they go
basically they're off the radar for
you know two months playing in the west
coast conference which was better this
year but they're still off the radar
playing you know for two months but uh
gonzaga is the blue blood i mean that's
just the way it is just like villanova
is a blue blood
gonzaga is the only team to make the
sweet 16 in each of the last six
tournaments
so that's good it shouldn't come as a
surprise
that you know they're they're this team
might be better than last year's team
yeah in relation to the field it is yeah
like this team's better in relation to
the field because the field last year
like baylor it's funny
i talked to mark few in the middle last
season and i said look your team's
playing really well blah blah he he gave
me this answer we're not baylor that was
last year
because baylor could dominate you in the
backcourt they they had a physicality
and toughness you know
mitchell and and and and and butler i
mean they were just so tough uh there's
no bailor out there this year so in
relation to the field
they might be better they have better
rib protection chet holmgren obviously
gives a better real protection timmy's a
year older doesn't have to do as much
obviously they don't have the guard but
andrew ebhardt's playing well
uh but there are other teams like
that team
in arizona
might might be baylor i don't know if
they are defensively on in the backcourt
but like arizona's baylor uh is gonzaga
2.0 with koloko's development as a room
protector and a gut front core guy that
can move his feet matheran and and dale
and perry are really good you know i
think arizona right now is playing the
best basketball anywhere in the country
six of arizona's top seven scores this
season
are from canada lithuania cameroon
estonia
mali
and sweden
what do you make of yeah being able to
recruit those kind of players all over
the world what
well i mean tommy lloyd he's the perfect
guy to coach that group you got to
remember now sean miller did a great job
of bringing those guys in he left those
guys now tommy lloyd had to re-recruit
them
because those guys could have all left
and been eligible immediately so when he
came in he was the right guy to hire
because you think about he had so much
experience with international recruiting
he had such a great network with
international recruiting so you know he
goes and he re-recruits them and they
all come back and then he puts him in a
system that's conducive to her skill set
but look that's the game our game is an
international game uh and they because
they will become just like gonzaga
became a destination for the best
international players
and you know to me that that's a huge
asset because now you're not banging
heads
with kentucky and kansas and duke in
north carolina for those kids because to
those kids you are kentucky duke north
carolina and kansas uh and because
that's the perception they have overseas
and you know recruiting's like is like
hamilton you got to have someone in a
room where it happens
and gonzaga because of the success
they've had with kids internationally
they have someone where it happens where
the decisions are being made
we're talking to seth greenberg espn
college basketball analyst uh best pro
prospect in the tournament is
i'm going to go outside the box i mean i
i've been vacillated on this for a while
but right now i'm leaning towards keegan
murray
keegan murray at iowa is a bucket he
gets off the bus he drops 25. look in
the new nba because of the size he's six
nine
could he lead iowa to a kempa type run
different kind of game
knocks down threes at 43 percent can
really defend very good passer could put
on the floor complain a post could
defend one through four
uh
i think that
he would be my first pick
i think jay knight who would my second
part john morant russell westbrook on a
good day and then jabari smith would be
my third i i have paul bancaro down the
road like like paul vancaro came in with
all this hype
and duke has had a lot of hype during
the course of season duke doesn't have
an identity defensively right now
they're i turn people over offensively
they got a lot of good players but they
it's almost like a little kid there's a
lot of toys for christmas doesn't know
which one to play with
uh but ben carroll
he shows it to you
but he doesn't show it to you like the
whole game he doesn't show t at the end
of the game he doesn't like you look at
him i'm saying
he's really good could he be jabari
parker could he be scott williams like i
want if i want to take a pic in the
first three a guy in the first three
pictures i wanted to be a guy that just
you know
that doesn't defer that wants to take
over again yeah he does disappear and uh
yeah
and i always look at when it gets
tighter
do you get larger do you
you know that's that's what i always
look for it's some guys have alligator
arms they don't want the ball and you
know this coaching
and and you you want that guy who says
give me the ball i got i was watching
durant yesterday you know closing time
against the knicks he was going to the i
want the ball i i want this shot i want
you to foul me i
those are the things that i gravitate
towards and i i love seeing that
mentality
i totally agree i like to think about
you think kobe's going to defer do you
think magic's going to defer you think
bird's going to defer you think lebron's
going to defer not more yeah he doesn't
have anything to defer to right now uh
so i mean you you look at the best
players in the history of the game
especially in a college game and you
want to you want like games online give
me the ball let's go i'll make a play
and if they double me i'll kick it out
now part of it is
and this is
my belief and i don't know the end of a
game you got to have understanding of
who you want to get get the ball to
where you want to get in the ball and
how you're going to get in the ball the
best teams that's what they do at the
end of the game
i'm not sure duke knows
where they want to get the ball and how
they want to get him the ball and if
they're going to win national
championship they better figure that out
in the next week yeah i don't know
i don't see him as i don't see him as a
national champion you see how they
played against syracuse
yes without buddy behind yeah yeah and
and you know what jim did a great job
coaching against duke
i mean the fact that that game was up in
the air and then you come back and then
you're thinking all right they're going
to they're going to breeze through the
acc like they're going to win this thing
and then virginia tech
you're almost like yeah they've roughed
them up not by alba they're not paying
me anymore they're not paying me anymore
i mean although i am i am a big mike
young fan i think he's a great guy and
he's done a great job and uh i'm really
i actually traded text messages with him
today i'm really happy for him that team
lost like seven out of nine the hardest
thing to do in coaching is you know is
to get a team back when they're
struggling to me that's the essence of
coaching keep your team to come to
practice every day to get better every
day and that's what that team did i was
really happy for him give me well give
this audience a team to keep an eye on
where you go all right if if if
everything goes right this team will do
some damage
well i i like iowa that that's not a
really reach i think that virginia tech
can win a couple of games in the
tournament uh
i think that uh
texas tech could be a team if they get
to gonzaga their their ability to keep
the ball on one side of the floor and be
really physical if they let him play
that's gonna be a team that could
can can do some damage for sure i think
all this here's my here's my big
takeaway
six eleven games i got all the elevens
um
all of them across the board okay 611
and then i have i have uh miami beat usc
in the in the 17. okay
all right
well keep an eye on it and uh always
great to talk to you yeah thanks for
having me and i'm not gonna blame you
when you're wrong
okay because usually what happens is you
don't get credit when you're right it's
just you get blamed when you're wrong oh
yeah
just send me an odyssey potter we'll be
fine odyssey putter
okay you bud
thanks that's uh seth greenberg espn
college basketball analyst there